i'll give you a great example there's a
story out about a mother
kyle i think her her name is kyle kyle
myers she is a utahn
i i thought people from utah were very
conservative apparently not this lady
she's the mother of a four-year-old
child who refuses to disclose whether
the child is a boy or a girl
and she says she's going to let the
child decide
his own gender i say his because his
is the uh singular gender neutral
pronoun
and this mother has now been accused of
child abuse
here's her take on it she says my
partner brent and i
not husband not boyfriend partner like
she's started an accounting firm or
something
my partner brent and i do something
called gender creative parenting
i believe gender is up to an individual
to determine and does not need to be
assigned at birth
i know a lot of people who are intersex
transgender and non-binary
i myself am a genderqueer woman who uses
they them
and she her pronouns so first of all
this woman is not genderqueer because
there's no such thing as genderqueer
it's a
meaningless expression and i think what
genderqueer really means is give me
attention
i'm a give me attention woman and i'm
really special give me attention
uh she says she knows a lot of intersex
transgender and non-binary people
she doesn't know any non-binary people
because that's not real she might know
some intersex you know that's where
you're born with some ambiguity as to
your
sex it's an exceedingly rare condition
and she might know some she may
certainly know some transgender people
men who think they're women or vice
versa
but she doesn't know a lot of them and
the way i know she doesn't know a lot of
them is there aren't a lot of them
because it's an extraordinarily
rare condition certainly the the
biological ambiguity on sex
is very rare and the psychological issue
is has been rare though it is growing by
leaps and bounds because
it has not only a psychological or
biological component but it has
a social component and it is a growing
as a social contagion particularly among
young people who are being abused by
their elders who should know better
like this lady's child gender
creative you cannot
have a functioning society in which
there is normal parenting and gender
creative parenting
you can't have at least on a broad scale
you can't have a functioning society
because those two expressions
make contrary ontological claims
to they make contrary
uh they begin from contrary premises
about
nature about biology about the human
person about how we all interact with
one another
about how education happens right
do you do you teach children do you
educate them do you raise them in a
certain way or do they in a sense teach
you
and then discover haphazardly the
reality of the world
right completely different views of
things she says
i believe gender is up to an individual
it's not it's not
it is a a given fact of nature and
nature doesn't change
i suspect this lady believes nature can
change which means it's it's not really
nature anymore
uh and it does not need to be assigned
at birth i am a genderqueer woman
no uh how can you be genderqueer and a
woman doesn't doesn't make a lot of
sense says i use they
them and she her pronouns well which is
it
is she multiple people maybe she might
she perhaps she has
issues with uh multiple personalities as
well she would appear to she's saying
i am two kinds of person at the same
time
if you have a society in which
men can be women and women can be men
then you don't have a society in which
men are men and women are women
and that has huge effects like
for instance actually i remember andrew
sullivan wrote andrew sullivan is a gay
sort of conservative writer
he wrote an essay a few years ago in
which he pointed this out he said if we
live in a society
with transgenderism then i can't be a
gay guy
and i can't be a gay guy because the
premises that i'm beginning with
are there are men and there are women
and sexual orientation
has a very strong biological component
to it and sort of hardwired in and i'm
born this way and you know i didn't
choose this or whatever
and so therefore i'm a gay guy right
if you live in the transgender world
there's no such thing as men or women
and it's not hardwired in not only can
you change your desires
you can change your sex itself you can
be a man
and then become a woman you can't live
in a functioning society with both of
those things
the reason that the left has sort of
encouraged all these various
contradictory new
standards and ethics is because
they attack the old system right and
with the the left when they wield
political correctness
it's a negative instrument it's an
instrument to just destroy the old
system
the old standards the old rituals the
old morades the old moral order
so it doesn't matter if they contradict
one another as long as you destroy the
old order you've
you've kind of accomplished your goal
but that is child abuse either it is
for this woman either it is child abuse
to
tell your child he doesn't have a sex
and he can pick it later on or it is
child abuse
to tell your child he has a sex and it
depends which premise you begin with but
you cannot have
both if you enjoyed that break from
disinformation historical
revision and screaming about the end of
the world be sure to hit the subscribe
button
so that you never miss another video
[Music]
you